hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the anxious rapid Division One
winner section it is Magnus Carlsen
versus we've seen what happened in the
first game this is the second game
Magnus won that beautiful end game with
the black pieces and now another back
needs to win a game to bounce back and
uh try and equalize the match and
hopefully for him maybe even win it so
let's see what happened here Magnus has
the white pieces and he opens with Pawn
to E4 and for those of you who have seen
my previous video I've mentioned that
we've finally finished our app for
learning chess after uh well some two
years so hope you guys are enjoying it
like I said in the previous video do
check it out first link in the
description below we are already
receiving quite a lot of suggestions
from you guys so uh you know keep at it
we are trying to make it as great as
possible we really appreciate every
every Insight you might give us on the
app like we will try to improve
everything so do try it out let us know
what you think and well hopefully
hopefully you enjoy it uh that being
said uh let's check out the game Ponte
E4 Pawn to C5 by another by going for
the Sicilian Defense Knight to F3 Pawn
to E6 and now Pawn to D4 uh open
Sicilian I mentioned in a couple of my
previous videos that people don't really
play the open Sicilian that much
nowadays everyone tries some C3 all up
in variation or even uh well uh just
Bishop to B5 uh Denis Medina rosolimo
but here at Magnus says I want to fight
let's play The Open Sicilian Pawn to D4
characters captures and now Knight to F6
with Bishop to D3 D6 and now usually you
will see Knight to C3 are just castles
here but Magnus plays Pawn to C4 it's a
really weird move only been played a
handful of times by not very very strong
players so this is uh it's a very weird
move to play sort of like going for the
maruti bind structure but with a bishop
and D3 just looks looks kind of weird
but okay a Magnus of course wants the
confusion a little bit as much as
possible and get a just a playable
position as soon as possible you know
just you know clear clear all Theory
from the game which I'm sure you guys
are enjoying the most as well so Bishop
D7 Knight to C3 we have A6 and now there
is a game where castles must play Magnus
just with Bishop to E3 and it is now as
of move eight that we have a completely
new game and Billy of course Bishops and
E3 and D3 this is a sign of a great
attacker you know that Paul Murphy
always put his Bishops on D3 and E3 uh
this will be an attacking game so we
have Castles by both players and now
Pawn to B6 another back prepares the
finchet with the dark Square the dark
light Square bishop and uh we'll just
put pressure on that e for Pawn the
Knight will also come to D7 then the C5
then put more pressure on e4 and Magnus
will have to figure out a way how to
keep the center closed so he can just
attack that King on the king side as the
Bishops are very nicely placed here so
here Pawn to F4 by Magnus we have Queen
the C7 uh we have rooked the C1 nicely
aligning The Rook with the queen and the
C file and Knight B to D7 and here
Magnus just plays Pawn to G4 and this is
uh whenever I face the Sicilian I have
similar structures you know I want to
play G4 I never know if if it's a good
idea if it's just you know if you will
create a devastating attack or will I
just weaken my king too much I always
play it sometimes I win sometimes I
don't but Magnus says all right well
let's just play it against another back
and it is in fact the strongest move
recommended by the engine so okay you
could go with Bishop B7 uh you could go
with Knight to C5 however you want to
play it as both moves will be played so
Knight the C5 first we have Bishop W1
you also don't want to give up your
light Square Bishop it's just a monster
piece and you want you want it there for
the rest of the game because probably uh
you will play something like Queen E1 to
H for to put pressure on H7 then The
Rook to F3 to H3 to put more pressure on
H7 these are just standard plans that
white will use to try and destroy the
Sicilian Defense and of course you know
that the knights are coming to D5 to F5
all the usual sacrifices the are
possible in positions like these so
Bishop to B7 we have Queen to F3 for the
moment you have to use your queen to
defend the pawn but it's all very
standard and now Pawn to G6 this is a
very interesting move because you know
that Magnus is planning Pawn to B4 you I
mean of course you know that and do you
play A5 here do you have time for A5 is
B4 a bigger threat of let's say Pawn to
F5 or Pawn to G5 just you know getting
uh
all your pieces into the attack do you
need the ways to move in order to kind
of limit the power of this uh Bishop on
B1 another back decides yes you do B4 is
not as big of a threat and he goes for
Pawn to G6 which again is the top move
recommended by the engine so brilliant
played by both players so far uh Magnus
of course continues would be for I would
argue against the engine but that's just
silly I mean I would of course play
Ponte A5 but okay Knight Theta D7 and
pawn to G5 now challenging the the
Knight here we have Knight to H5 and now
Knight to D5 now it looks a bit scary
and of course if you're playing with the
black pieces you will be like oh no I'm
just getting destroyed here but if
you're a zillion player uh you should
not be scared off by this Knight the D5
sacrifice it's pretty standard everyone
does it and you should just you know get
get used to it so Knight to D5 what do
you do do you capture the Knight well we
could try the short answer is you can
capture it the long answer is you can
capture it but maybe you don't want to
uh but because then comes Knight to F5
and what now of course if you capture
the second Knight then you're just gonna
capture this first we uh again some
activity here we kick away the black
queen and then we capture an H5 and then
this will be a problem this will be a
problem maybe bishop coming to D4 will
be a problem too many problems for that
one piece you're just not getting
anything for it but after you capture
the Knight to F5 you don't have to
capture this Knight as well you could
just play Queen to d8 and the game
continues with something like e
characters on D5 again you never really
want to capture this you could just
start re-maneuvering let's say Knight to
H6 checking goes here Queen to H3 and
it's a game it's uh the engine literally
gives zero zero here of course when
you're playing a position like this you
do not feel it's a zero zero uh so you
know another break decides against that
he just plays Queen to d8 he wants to
defend his Bishop on E7 and Magnus says
I will Gradle gradually you know
eliminate your Bishop pair so captures
captures and queen the H3 now putting a
significant pressure on this E6 spawn
you know that F5 is coming so another
big just defends it probably The Rook
would come to C8 if not for this
pressure but he feels that there's too
much pressure so he just helps out with
the defense uh we have Rook seat the E1
and now we have Queen back to d8 we have
Knight the EQ now the Knight is coming
to G3 and you want to get rid of uh well
one of the Defenders of the black king
So Pawn to E5 but Magnus just plays Pawn
to F5 we have Pawn to F6 and usually we
say that uh when you play Pawn to F6
with black it's either losing or is the
strongest move in this case it is the
strongest move just putting pressure on
that G5 Pawn uh the queen of course of
course helping out but Magnus just
strengthens it so Queen to H4 we have
Rook to F7 now preparing to double up on
the f file before opening up the
position and Rook to D1 we have Queen to
C7 and now Bishop to D3 guarding the the
pawn here uh the D6 Pawn yes it's a very
weak backward spawn but the Magnus for
the moment is not very very interested
in that pawn he wants to attack the
black king we have Rook e to f8 and now
G captures on F6 we have Knight D
captures and now Bishop to H6 and the
problem is it's just not
um easy to get rid of that uh This
Thread you could of course play
something like Knight to G7 then comes
Knight to G3 and Black's position is
just looking incredibly weird on the
other hand if you try to move the Rook
it's not as great just let's say
captures captures a knight to G3 now
you're really passive here you can never
really trade here because then you
weaken this Knight now Bishop T2 is
coming you're gonna uh it's not losing
by force just in a rapid game with
little time on the clock it's incredibly
difficult to spot moves so instead Pawn
to G5 another big says all right let's
play active chess let's give up one Pawn
let's open up the G file and then maybe
I can also use it to attack the white
king So Okay Magnus Not Afraid Queen
captures on G5 checking h8 and now
Bishop captures Santa Fe this also comes
with with an exchange sacrifice but
Notre back
well would rather do that than to play a
passive position so Knight to G3 so you
don't include the queen with Rook to G8
Rook to Jade and queen to H6 with Queen
to F7 and now Bishop to E2 getting ready
to uh trade some pieces here but now
Knight the F4 and this is a remarkable
Knight here and Magnus of course would
rather see it gone from the board than
enjoy being up the exchange so he gives
back the exchange captures an F4 Pawn
captures Queen captures and now Knight
captures an E4 made possible as the
Knight and G3 cannot move so King to F1
and now Queen to G7 and now how do you
proceed here well uh there are many many
possibilities but another week is very
low on time and Magnus just pushes F6
point is that you can't trade Queens if
you trade Queens then just captures
captures and will captures you're up
upon you're gonna win another one and
you're gonna win the game so of course
noidback has the capture back with the
Knight and now Magnus goes King to E1 uh
probably uh not probably deciding that
the king will be safest in the middle of
the board but maybe even uh thinking
about hiding the king all the way to the
queen side so here we have Queen to E7
and now Queen captures on D6 Magnus just
grabs a pawn another big again avoids
the queen trade as he will be worse in
an end game and Magnus grabs another
opponent now he says I'm up two pawns if
you can't Checkmate me I just win the
game so noidback has to try Rook to E8
uh and Magnus goes Rook to D eighth he's
up to points he wants to trade of course
that's the way to do it Rook captures
Queen captures and now Knights the G8 uh
stopping check but now comes Knight to
F5 and the black queen now must remain
on this diagonal otherwise something
like Queen to D4 check just ends the
game on the spot so Queen the C3 check
King to F2 and he was in this position
animal 43 that Northern caval resigned
to the game as there is nothing more to
be done here now you you're down two
pawns if you collect one one Pawn then
just Queen D4 track and your other moves
you are getting checkmated so that's
pretty much it and if you don't do this
uh well like I said you're you're down
to pawns magnets will force a queen
trade with something like Queen D4 and
then of course just easily win the end
game being up two Pawns yeah very nicely
done by Magnus he wins the first game
beautiful end game if he wins the second
game just completely out playing another
back and the third game ended in a draw
which means that Magnus is the winner of
the anxious rapid Division One winner
section and he qualifies for the Grand
Final uh and of course we will also be
covering that once uh it comes to that
uh but yeah very nicely done if you have
some other games that were really uh
good and you you guys would enjoy uh
dissecting them do use hashtag
suggestion and I will go over them uh
but this is pretty much it from the
tournament uh Magnus wins it all he wins
it all whatever he plays so you know we
have to we have to wait for an another
person to to challenge him uh here he
didn't find much competition so I really
really hope you guys enjoy that once
again do try out our wrap first link in
the description below we really enjoy
your your input we really want to make
it as great as possible do try it and if
you want to learn a little bit more
about it I gave a pretty pretty long
introduction in the previous video so do
do check it out and yeah I would like
thank James Eugene Cashman Brad Roth
Michael Marshall bullichertthriller.com
and John Malpass for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you one of our
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day